it's hard to miss daily reminders of the
globalized marketplace we live in
with the goods and services we use
coming from the four corners of the
world
but the playing field isn't quite so
level as it may appear
or as many here in europe would wish for
particularly when it comes to
multi-billion euros state procurement
contracts
according to parliament european
companies could be losing billions of
euros because access to major services
urban and national infrastructure
projects is blocked
but the mep steering new legislation to
redress that through parliament
says that although europe's markets are
open there's plenty of room for more
foreign
but we're still in the belly of an
economic recession and not everyone
agrees with flinging open the doors of
europe's markets to outsiders
the proposals call for more leverage for
europe on market access
for powers to investigate and follow up
restrictive practices in a relevant
country
and to block market access in europe to
companies from that country if necessary
the proposal passed the first committee
stage comfortably and will go to plenary
for a first reading